Nhưng mà nhớ là đi, làm thì em nghĩ là
Thì thần kia lợi hơn, thì tên như vào
Đi nó cho đó cho anh anh
Đi là hình đến hành nghiên bà trẻ sức hành cho chức in từ mấy cái sáng ngày tham
Năm trong sự kiện lớn nhất bị đam giận cho công đồng yếu game
Đi đam game birth thay thông khai sấu
Năm đầu tiên bản phép
Suy kiến kiến giận phá binh ngạn bế được bán ra trước thêm hai mặt
Chờ thay sự khúc lớn của sự kiện với công đồng
Mời đen hình thường hình thường thật của do
Nếu để đó cũng tòi thám thấy em trẻ của các lấy hành hoa
Vì thông trong khá thông tỏ, chi cũng có thể đánh ăn đoàn
Nói bắt trẻ cả khi em, cho cơ ở đây
Thuy hình thơ cho cũng là ngon ngon ngon ngon chú trở
Đắm này, quy mô sự kiện được mở trong với nhiều phạt động
Víu chả xuy xuất trong hai ngày tham, và ngày chiến thêm năm
Như giữ đàn game become cosplay contest
Lấy chào gái, việc đam game awards.
Thì đấu game arena, giá lùi bình hủy esports.